- Hello, welcome to this
Monday's daily homeroom.
For those of you all who are new here,
this is something we're trying to do
to keep us all connected
as we have these school closures going on
throughout the world.
Many of y'all know Khan Academy,
we're a not for profit
with a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
And when we found out
that the school closures were happening,
we realized that we had to do many things.
That as a not for profit
with this mission,
we had to step up to support you,
students, parents, and
teachers, any way we could.
So we had already, over
the last many years,
we could have never
foreseen this situation.
We had built content.
There's Khan Academy kids,
which is for the young crowd,
ages two to six in reading, writing,
social emotional learning.
And then on Khan Academy,
not Khan Academy kids,
you can continue on in math,
English and language arts, the sciences,
humanities, SAT practice.
And we realized that we
should also do things
that can help structure your day.
So we released some of
those daily schedules out
a couple of weeks ago
that we've heard good
feedback from all of y'all.
We've been doing parent webinars,
teacher webinars,
and we are doing this daily homeroom,
which is a place to answer
any questions you might have.
So as you listen, definitely and whether
it's on Facebook or YouTube,
type in questions for myself or our guest,
who is gonna be Adam Green
from our content team.
And we're going to try to answer
as many as we can
over the course of the next few minutes.
I do wanna give a special thanks
to several corporations
who have stepped up
in the last couple of weeks.
Khan Academy is funded with
philanthropic donations.
And we were running at
a deficit even before
our traffic spiked by
two and a half, three X
over the last couple of weeks.
And Bank of America followed
by AT&T, google.org,
and Novartis have really stepped up
and helped us close some of that gap.
But I do wanna emphasize
any corporations listening
or any individuals listening,
every dollar matters.
We are still running at a deficit,
and we want the resources
to be able to support you
as well as possible.
And folks who are not
in a position to donate
so that everyone has access to things
that can bridge them
through this time period.
So keep putting your questions
in on YouTube and Facebook.
And I'd like to introduce
our guest, Adam Green,
who runs
who's the head of our U.S. content
on Khan Academy.
Adam, good to see you.
- Good to see you.
Thanks Sal.
We're also joined here by Pistachio.
I know some of the folks in the office,
Pistachio usually comes
into the office with me
and I know that they're missing her.
So I wanted to say hello from her.
And also there's a neighborhood cat
that she usually likes to bark
at about this time of day.
So this is the best way to make sure
that she's not going to be barking
during this conversation,
but a great to see you.
Thanks Sal.
- Yes, I have, I have a mixed
feelings towards Pistachio.
One of the cutest dogs I know,
(Adam laughing)
but I think they know that
and so doesn't always
give me the attention
that I think I deserve.
(laughing)
- Treats. Treats are the way to go.
- Treats.
Yeah, bribery.
I don't normally pay for, anyway.
What Adam,
maybe the place to start
for everyone listening
is what do you do here at Khan Academy
and what does the content
team do here at Khan Academy?
- Sure, thanks.
Yeah, so I lead the content team,
the U.S. academic content team,
which basically means I work
with about 15 people
that are all really
amazing content experts
in everything from math
to science to humanities,
social studies, English language arts,
and we all work together
to build all the great content
that you see on Khan Academy
for those core courses.
And we're constantly --
- And how does it work?
- Working to add more.
You know, go ahead.
Go ahead Sal.
- Yeah, well actually
going on to adding more.
One question I always get is,
well, how does Khan Academy
determine what content to add?
And then how does it go
about adding that content?
Like what's a day in the life
of a content team member
here at Khan Academy?
- Sure. I think that's one of the things
if you were to ask a content creator,
that's one of the things that
they really like about the job
is that there's all
sorts of different things
that can be happening
depending on where you are in
the life cycle of a course.
So we do a lot of research to figure out
what really does do learners
and teachers need out there.
So, everything from surveying teachers
to looking at lesson
plans that are out there,
to looking at state
and national standards,
to see really what can we
provide on our platform
that can be of highest use
to learners and teachers out there.
So we do that research phase
and then there's a whole
series of different phases
for content building
depending on what type of content
we're actually working on.
If it's videos, articles, exercises,
all of those go through a
pretty stringent review process,
both internally and externally
as we create those resources.
So we'll be building them as a team.
The math team will get
together and decide,
hey, we need to do more geometry.
We have to add geometry exercises
in the next couple months.
That's what we've determined
will be the most use to, to
teachers and learners out there.
So they'll start to build that.
They'll build a plan.
Then they'll be building those exercises.
Reviewing them internally
and then sending them for external review
to trusted teachers and
other folks out there,
other content experts.
And then we'll publish them on the site
and then we're not done there.
We get a lot of feedback from folks,
like the folks that are watching
this YouTube live stream right now.
We looked at every single one
of those pieces of feedback
that we get from folks out there.
And then we'll take
that into consideration
when we work to improve the content
that we've put out.
- And what's in the queue right now?
What can users out there expect to see,
either improvements or new courses
over the next couple of months?
- Yeah, great question.
So we're,
some of those were
pushing out more quickly
than we originally anticipated.
We had a whole bunch of stuff planned
for the summer
and some those things
we're releasing earlier
because of this crisis
that we're in right now.
So you might've seen
we have new AP biology
and AP chemistry content that's out there
to help students with AP courses.
We have all sorts of English
language arts content
that's been coming out
and will continue to come out
over the next couple of months.
And we have big refreshes on the math side
in geometry and in algebra.
And those are, those are
sort of the big projects
that are happening right now.
And in the pipeline we
have all sorts of other,
other projects for
improvements in physics,
AP physics one.
And also we're looking to,
to build a civics course
that hopefully the first
part of that civics course
should be out this summer.
And then we have a whole
new world history project
that we've developed in partnership
with the Gates Foundation.
And that's actually hopefully
gonna be coming live
tomorrow on this site,
which is very exciting.
- Oh, it's very, yeah,
all of this is very exciting stuff.
So we're getting a lot of
questions about AP exams.
But I do want to let
everyone know that the,
the president and CEO of the CollegeBoard,
the folks who make the AP
and the SAT,
he's going to be on this
live stream tomorrow.
David Coleman.
But Adam, what, how should someone
who is thinking about the AP exams,
I guess we're about,
oh really were weeks away from it now.
How would you recommend students
typically prepare for
it using Khan Academy?
And I know there's a lot of,
you know, consternation maybe
about how things might
be different this year.
What advice are you giving the students,
especially relative to how
they could use our resources?
- Yeah, there's a lot packed in there.
So I'll start off by talking about
how I would recommend using our resources.
And I think that you have some,
you've had some good advice
in the past too on that.
And we have a whole support page
that we've dedicated to the AP
be different this year
and how you can use Khan
Academy resources to help you.
But I think that really
the first thing that I would suggest
is to make an account.
It's free to do that.
You can use our resources
without making an account,
but by having that free account,
you can track your progress
and really use all of the tools
available on Khan Academy
that will help show you
what you need to practice
a little bit more
and what maybe you can
practice a little bit less
to get prepared for the,
for the exam.
So once you make that account,
I think that there's
really one of two paths
that I would recommend.
If you're the kind of student
where you know that there's a unit
or some topic in the AP subject course
that you're about to to take the exam for.
If you know that there's a particular unit
that you need to brush up on,
then I would just go right
to that unit on Khan Academy.
Let's say you're an AP statistics student
and you know,
probability has been
kind of getting you down,
then you can go right to
the AP statistics course
and jump into that unit
and start practicing.
Watch some videos and articles.
Read some articles,
and then do some practice to,
to get boned up on the,
brushed up on those sorts of,
on that sort of topic
and really feel more comfortable
with that particular unit.
If you're not sure where you should start
or you're already feeling pretty good,
then my suggestion would be
to jump right to the course challenge.
Most of the AP courses
that Khan Academy offers
have practice content.
Most of those courses will also
have mastery enabled features.
And one of those master enabled features
is the course challenge.
So if you scroll all the way down
to the bottom of any particular AP course,
you'll see course challenge.
You can click that button.
It's like a 30 to 45
minute investment in time.
It's 30 questions.
And that really gives you
a big survey of all of the
different types of questions
that you're likely to
see in the entire course.
Once you get through that,
you'll get a bit of a report
that shows you sort of
how you're doing on those
and it can tell you which topics
that we think that you should
focus on a little bit more.
Keep in mind that the AP format
is a bit different this year
and one of the pieces that's different
is the amount of content
that's gonna be covered
on that exam.
In most cases it's about 75% of the course
or what most course,
most classrooms will have covered
by early March of this year.
And these course challenges,
they cover everything.
So you,
in my opinion,
you should try to get
through all of the content
for that course
because that'll really prepare you for
for the best experience in college
if you end up applying this
credit to college credits.
But the AP exam, this year itself,
will only cover the first
about 75% of of the class.
And you can get more information
about what that means,
which units are covered and not covered,
both in that AP support post
that that we have on,
on Khan Academy
and also through the CollegeBoard website,
where you can get really specific details
about which units will
be covered on the exam
and which ones won't
be covered on the exam.
So those are sort of the two ways
that I would approach it.
Targeted practice.
If you know you need targeted practice
and if you're not quite sure
you're feeling pretty good,
then jump into that course challenge
and let our tools tell you
where you might want to focus on more.
But you may have other
suggestions too Sal.
I'd love to hear from you.
- Oh, well everything you just said,
I think what, you know,
in previous years,
the standard AP format is you have,
you know, roughly half multiple choice
and then you have the
free response section.
And I think the Khan Academy,
you know, our modality,
we have multiple choice
and we also have things
like free response,
numeric entry, not you know,
long form free response.
But that really prepares
you historically well
for the multiple choice section of the AP.
And I think to a reasonable
degree for the free response.
But what I've always told students is
get to as much mastery as
you can on Khan Academy
Just as like this you mentioned.
And then a few days or
weeks before the exam,
go through the worked examples
of the free response
questions on Khan Academy.
These are in video format.
And you know, when I or
some other content creator
gives the question,
pause it, try to solve it on your
by yourself before we solve it.
And that'll really help
you for the free response.
And I think that same combination,
it's going to be really
effective for this year.
Where it's gonna be a shorter
free response focused,
virtually proctored exam.
But I think either way, as Adam mentioned,
that's what's going to make you feel
very comfortable and confident
in this year's exams.
So we have some questions--
- Yeah so to double down.
Even before you go on Sal.
Just to double down on that.
Not only do we have those
free response videos
that students can use in
that sort of active way
to really pause the video,
try on their own.
And then,
and then watching your response to that.
In the AP resources blog posts
that we have on Khan Academy,
we have links to free response questions
from previous exams.
For most exams it's the last three years,
those go right to CollegeBoard
and have PDFs of the
free response questions
that you can practice
with, along with responses
and scoring guides for each of those.
So although that most of our questions
in the AP courses on Khan Academy
are multiple choice or
something close to it,
they're all designed really
with being able to answer free
response questions in mind.
They take you through the thought process
and the sort of modeling that thought
that you would need in
order to be successful
in the free response questions.
So, even though you may be practicing
and using the mastery system,
using something multiple
choice or close to it,
you're really laying that foundation
to have a firm understanding
of all of the content
that you need in order to be successful
in those free response questions.
So yeah, I would do mastery stuff first,
then I would watch the Sal videos
that go through the
free response questions
from the past few years.
And then finally at the end,
I would look at those
CollegeBoard resources
for free response questions
and try to work through those on your own
and look at those scoring guides
and sample responses.
And following that
progression over the next
you know, four to six weeks
or potentially a little bit longer
depending on when your exam actually is,
you should be in pretty good shape.
There's a lot of resources
out there for everybody.
Plus there's CollegeBoard resources
like YouTube videos
that they're doing live
YouTube review sessions
for all of the different courses
and you can get information for that
both on our AP blog posts
and also on the CollegeBoard website.
- Super, super useful.
And let's see, we have some questions.
This is from YouTube.
Pamela Criswell asks,
what is your suggestion for the best ways
for teachers to use Khan Academy
since we have had to
go to remote learning?
I could take a first stab of that Pamela
and I'd love to hear what you
have to say as well, Adam.
So I think there's several ways
that you could use Khan Academy.
Before the school closures,
when school was in session,
what we've seen is
if teachers are able
to have their students
work on personalized learning,
mastery learning on Khan Academy,
even 45 minutes a week,
that that has been associated
with accelerated outcomes
on a wide variety of measures.
And that is something like,
let's say you're a sixth grade teacher,
you can assign the sixth
grade course mastery
to your students
and that's something
that could take all year.
So could take a good amount of time,
until the kids over the year
are going to learn
their own time and pace,
try to get things a leveled up
and you as a teacher
are going to get a dashboard
where you can see who's progressing,
who's not, who's engaged, who's not,
who's getting stuck on certain concepts.
And then in a class time,
you can take some of
the kids who are stuck
and you could do a focused
intervention with them.
You can maybe pair them up
or you could pair them with a student
who might have already
mastered that concept.
We've seen that work really well.
Now that we have this
school closure situation,
what we're seeing a lot of teachers do
is lean on that a little bit more.
Where they can now expect
instead of 45 minutes a week,
depending on the age group,
anywhere between 20 to 60 minutes a day
of being able to work on their math
at their own time and pace.
One of the things we did a few weeks ago
is we released these daily
schedule for students
of different age groups.
That articulated, hey,
for this age group,
maybe 45 minutes of Khan Academy math
at this time of the day might make sense.
What we're going to be releasing
over the next couple of days
are actually learning plans
where not just over through
the end of the school year,
but also potentially leveraging the summer
so students can make sure
that they have a plan
to cover all of the major concepts
that they need to be at
grade level or above.
For students who maybe are weak
in some of their foundations,
we recommend, let's say their
sixth grade students again,
keep going on fifth grade,
but simultaneously also try to get mastery
on arithmetic on Khan Academy
to make sure they have
really, really, really strong foundations.
Now as a teacher,
one of the things I think we've
seen teachers do really well
is if there's a certain time of day
kids are working on Khan Academy
at their own time and pace,
you can monitor that.
But also if you could
make yourself available
via Google Hangouts or Zoom
or something like that,
where students can jump on
maybe a couple of times a week,
ask you questions,
you can work through
work examples with them,
and it really should feel like a tutorial
because everyone's looking for
that social connection right now.
So the more interactive it is the better.
So I think something like that,
that type of flow is really powerful
and also encouraging parents
and students to continue
through the summer.
You know we're in a tough
scenario right over here
where it looks like most of the country,
schools are going to be closed
probably through the
end of the school year
and so there's a loss there of two months,
but then there's an opportunity
to maybe leverage the summer as well
to make sure students are at grade level.
Adam, anything to add to that?
- [Adam] No, I think you covered
that really, really well.
- [Sal] All right.
And I'll, if we think of more
and all of you teachers out there,
a lot of what we are trying
to recommend to teachers
is coming from teachers doing a great job.
So we're all learning this together.
So send us your ideas as well.
And so there is,
so a quick question.
So Camille B P (mumbles) says,
do we have content for TOEFL?
Unfortunately, we do
not have TOEFL content.
That's the test for foreign students
who need to show English proficiency.
We don't have that yet,
or we don't have plans for that.
Let's see, we have a
question from YouTube.
Susanna Garcia Dominguez says,
how can I use your science course
to prove that I have mastered
middle school science?
So I have a few ideas, but Adam,
I'd love your take on that.
- Yeah.
That's a--
We don't have specific content out
for middle school classrooms yet.
That's something that we're
hoping to work on in the future.
But right now, I would
take a look at things
like high school biology.
We do have courses in
chemistry and in physics.
And if you can work your
way through those courses,
and we have all of those
resources on Khan Academy,
that if you're a really motivated student,
which it sounds like you really are,
then you can watch those
videos, read articles,
and you can continue to
practice those exercises
over and over and see
new types of questions.
And that's going to be a really great way
for you to start to to build
that mastery in those courses.
In terms of being able to
show that you've done that,
I think that just having
that knowledge in your head
and being able to talk with
that with your teachers
and fellow students is the best way
that we can help support that right now.
But Sal what do you think?
- Yeah, I would just add to that.
What I've been telling a
lot of students is that,
you know, some of these courses
that are labeled high school courses,
you could try engaging in.
This is a great time to try it out.
I think high school biology
is something that a lot
of middle school students
can engage in.
You know, the math you need,
you already have.
And you know, you start
learning the basics.
What is life? What is DNA?
RNA? Obviously what's a virus?
Very, very relevant things right now.
I think we're all a little bit
more motivated than normal
and to learn about
viruses, and RNA, and DNA,
and things like that.
And also on the math
side, exponential growth.
So, I recommend high school biology
is a great place to go.
And if as a middle school student,
you're able to engage in,
it's going to be a great leg up,
not just for high school and college.
It's going to be a great.
You'll sound smarter at
dinner parties these days.
If you talk about how RNA is
more likely to mutate than NBA,
you'll be able to keep up
with some of the biologists out there.
So that's what I would recommend.
I'm actually even doing
it with some of my kids.
Cause everyone's curious
right now about this.
And I think you're ready to learn it,
especially if you have
that motivation to do so.
So let's see,
we have from Facebook, Jane Molnar says,
any plans for upper division math classes
like abstract algebra, complex analysis?
So I hear you,
you know, as a math nerd,
I'm talking to myself
in the most affectionate possible way.
I would love to do that at some point.
Our focus has been
trying to do the courses
that the most students have the
most trouble with right now.
But I hope one day we do get into
some of the more advanced.
We do have things
like multi-variable
differential equations,
linear algebra,
but you're really talking about,
a complex analysis really is
around that level as well.
So I hope we are able to get there
over the next many years,
but it's not part of
our pipeline just yet.
Okay. So I have a Facebook,
Adam (mumbles) to Sal and Adam.
How will Khan Academy
get me into Stanford?
(both laughing)
Adam, I don't think
that's our job. (chuckles)
- That's a not directly our job.
- Not directly our job. (chuckles)
What I will say,
as I'm putting my
guidance counselor hat on,
is first I wouldn't over
index on any one school.
It's really more of what you make of it.
But my advice generally,
and it's great to have to say,
hey, you know,
this school or that school
is where I could imagine
myself, is just be curious.
Learn as much as you can.
Do it for authentic reasons.
Do other interesting things
above and beyond your academics,
but don't do it just
to be able to fill out
a college application.
The college admissions folks that I know
are good at spotting you know,
engineered applications.
They like authenticity.
And you know,
just to get to know
who you are as a person
and how you might be able
to contribute to the world.
And then when you apply to colleges,
just be your authentic self.
Don't try to be some
version of what you think
that admissions officer wants to see.
And if for whatever reason,
your true authentic self
isn't what gets you in
to some school, well that's probably good.
It's like a marriage.
(chuckles) If your true authentic self
and the other person
doesn't want to marry you,
well it's good to know
before you get married.
Than after the fact. (laughing)
So my advice is just be curious, learn,
use this time right now to
work on interesting things.
Ways to help your community,
inventions, or whatever else.
You know, I've been thinking about it.
Wouldn't it be cool if there are gloves,
that not only protect you from the virus,
but kill the virus on anything it touches.
You know. I've been walking
into the supermarket
with like Clorox wipes on both hands
and I go to like the milk.
I open it up. (chuckles)
I'm like, not only am I protecting myself,
but I'm protecting the next
person to open this door.
So I think there's plenty of
opportunity for invention.
Adam, any advice you have for Adam?
- (laughing) Great name?
Yeah, I think that the
that what you're saying
rings really true.
College admissions, counselors,
and all those folks,
have seen it all before.
They're gonna know if you're
just writing for that,
you should really be writing for yourself.
Be yourself and yeah,
just to, as Sal said,
be curious about the world around you
and just be your authentic self,
both before, during, and after
the college admissions process.
And things will generally work out.
- Yeah.
And we have this question from Instagram.
Sarah_Moe66 says,
what if students do not have
reliable access to the internet.
My advice is,
you know,
videos are a little bit harder
with intermittent access to the internet.
Our exercise platform
does leverage the internet
to be able to keep track
of what you're doing.
You're not, but it's not that intensive
from a data point of view.
So you should be able to
work on the exercises,
get the feedback.
And our Khan Academy's
iPhone or tablet and phone app
actually does allow you
to download and think,
so you can do that kind
of thing overnight.
And then you have a little bit
more consistent of an experience.
But this is a major problem.
There's obviously a lot of kids,
not just in the United States,
but around the world, who
don't have access to internet.
And we're going to,
you know, we're not the folks
who can distribute laptops
or distribute internet,
but we are trying to work
with telecom carriers
and other folks
to see how we can help solve that issue.
Let's see.
Other questions that we are seeing.
We are seeing.
So YouTube Abel [Iiaudible] says,
what can I do on Khan
Academy during this time?
I don't know, Adam,
do you want to take a first stab at that?
There's a lot that you could do.
- So many things.
There are literally hundreds of courses
on Khan Academy that you
can play around with.
So I would suggest mixing
things up a little bit
if you if you're in bio,
if you're in high school biology course,
or if you're, you know, in
fifth grade taking math,
do a little bit of work in those courses.
But also just sort of look around,
poke around and follow your nose,
follow your, whatever you
happen to be interested in.
We have content on there from Pixar.
Pixar in a box.
If you're interested in animation.
We have lots of computing
courses on there.
So if you're interested
in computer science
or learning something about programming,
you can poke around in there.
There's just a lot going on on
in the Khan Academy universe
and I would just suggest
kinda opening things up
and looking at something
that maybe you haven't looked at before
or something that you've
heard might be interesting
and just play around.
It's an open sandbox
and I think that you'll find some,
you'll find a lot of things in there
that will be interesting to you,
especially in this time,
where you might have a
little bit more time,
or a little bit more flexibility
to get interested in things.
- [Sal] And I'll just add
to what Adam said, Abel.
Abell or Abel.
You know, this bad situation
that the world finds itself in it,
there's a silver lining,
that you now have time.
And if you can structure your day.
You have every day you could spend,
you know, sessions,
I don't know how old you are,
but you could spend sessions
of 20 minutes at a time,
30 minutes at a time,
maybe three or four of those sessions.
You could make sure you have
super solid foundations in math
by doing everything that
we've been talking about,
not just in this live stream,
but in previous ones,
where you can get practice feedback,
take that course challenge.
If you're feeling a little
bit weak in these subjects,
you can remediate with things
like our arithmetic course
or a pre algebra course.
And if you're feeling good,
just keep going between now
and the start of school.
I can't tell you enough how
confident that will make you
in whatever subject you you engage in.
So that can be in math.
I encourage folks who feel they're ready,
even at the middle school level,
especially at the high school level,
get a leg up on biology,
chemistry and physics.
Because you have the time now,
but then a year or two from now
when you're taking those courses
and you're taking six or seven courses
and you have homework,
you're like, oh I wish
I used those five months
a little bit better.
I would also encourage
you read a lot right now
and think critically about that reading.
I would, even if you're not planning
on taking the SAT in
the next several months,
I actually think the SAT
practice on Khan Academy
that we've been doing
with the CollegeBoard,
it's not just in math, it's in
reading and writing as well.
It's just great practice in general
to sharpen those skills
and get you ready for college.
It's related to this question
from YouTube, Sri Harsha (mumbles) says,
do you guys have plans
to do a guide for the GRE
as y'all have done for the SAT?
And Sri Harsha is very generous.
You guys really, really
helped me out on this
and I can't thank you guys enough.
Well thank you Sri Harsha.
Unfortunately, we don't
have GRE prep right now.
But you know,
I think that SAT prep is
fairly general purpose.
A lot of folks have also
asked about the ACT.
Alison Gabble on Facebook asked about it.
We don't have ACT specific prep either,
but once again, if you get really good,
these things are all
highly, highly correlated.
SAT, GRE, ACT.
If you use our SAT work and
get really strong at it,
that's going to transfer
I believe to other tests.
So it looks like we're all at time,
it's always fun.
I want to thank Adam for joining us.
He does, you know,
a lot of folks think that Khan Academy
is still a walk in closet,
although I am backing up.
I'm in my, in our kids kind
of a work room right now.
But it's a team effort.
And what you see as a finished product
of over 200 folks, Adam
leads a large chunk of that.
And you know, folks hopefully appreciate
that there's a lot of folks
who are dedicating their time
and energy to this effort.
And I want to thank all of them.
And you know, before we head out,
I just want to remind everyone,
you know, stay safe, stay
healthy, stay socially distant.
That's the best way that
we can stop the spread
of what we're all going through.
And I want to thank you for joining
because not only is this a way
for all of you to feel connected,
it's a way for us to
feel connected to you.
Which we all need right now.
And I'll just say again,
a reminder Khan Academy
is a not for profit.
We are dependent on
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
Every dollar matters.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
You can see the links at the end.
It's khanacademy.org/donate.
Thank you so much.
Have a great Monday.